[Música]
Muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de verdad muchas gracias saben en los
últimos cuatro años hemos visto unos
grandes desafíos para el pueblo de
nuestro estado para los ciudadanos de
los Estados Unidos y por encima de todo
por la causa de la libertad hemos visto
la libertad y nuestro estilo de vida en
esta y tantas jurisdicciones del país
estaban en riesgo y Florida sostuvo la
lucha
elegimos los hechos por encima del
terror elegimos la educación por encima
de la indoctrinación
de lado de entrenamiento
elegimos la ley y el orden sobre el
desorden y el caos Florida fue Un
refugio para la sanidad cuando el mundo
entró en locura
fuimos una cita de la de la Libertad
para la gente de este país y para todo
el mundo
[Aplausos]
enfrentamos un impuesto tomamos los
golpes
sobrevivimos la tormenta pero mantuvimos
nuestros argumentos no retrocedimos
tuvimos la convicción para guiarnos a
nosotros mismos si tuvimos el coraje de
liderar hicimos promesas
[Aplausos]
hicimos promesas al pueblo de la Florida
y las Hemos cumplido
[Aplausos]
entonces hoy después de cuatro años el
pueblo ha cumplido y entregado su
veredicto la libertad está acá y está
para quedarse
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas muchas gracias muchas gracias
ahora gracias a la avasallador respaldo
del pueblo de la Florida no solamente
llegamos una elección sino que hemos
reescrito el mapa político
estadounidense
[Aplausos]
Gracias por honrarnos con esta Victoria
que durará muchos años
quiero agradecerle a todo nuestro equipo
de campaña desde el manager de la
campaña general
esta fue la campaña mejor manejada en la
historia de la política de la Florida
quiero agradecerle a todos nuestros
maravillosos voluntarios que trabajaron
muy duro para hacer que lograran el voto
su respaldo significa el mundo para mí
para que decidió Dios los bendiga Muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
ahora es mucho más fácil manejar una
buena campaña cuando hay una gran
registro para hacerlo y no podría ver
este nivel de logros que pudimos ver De
no ser que tuviera
a un gran personal en la oficina
ejecutiva del gobernador así como
manejando las agencias estatales esas
personas trabajaron muy duro para
implementar nuestra agenda creyeron en
nuestra gente ahí en los resultados y
los resultados han sido históricos
gracias por su respaldo gracias por su
trabajo
Muchas gracias a Miami Dade del Condado
de Miami Dade
[Aplausos]
Muchas gracias a el condado de Palm
Beach
ahora todavía estamos contando los votos
pero es claro y aparente que esta
elección nos ha significado un número
significativo de votos de personas que
pudieron no haber votado por mí hace
unos años quiero decirles que me honra
haber ganado su confianza y su respaldo
en estos cuatro años
[Aplausos]
mucho más importante Gracias
la mejor primera dama en todos los 50
estados
[Aplausos]
por ser una gran esposa por darme un
respaldo incesante por ser una madre
tremenda para nuestros tres niños
y sirviendo como ejemplo para mujeres en
todo el estado especialmente aquellas
que pasan por la batalla del cáncer ella
es sobresaliente
[Aplausos]
ahora hoy es la culminación
de las acciones de 2022 pero en realidad
los estadounidenses han estado votando
por muchos años ya han estado votando
con sus pies y el resultado de ese
comportamiento han sido tan oscuro como
la victoria más alládora de hoy estados
o ciudades gobernadas por políticos de
izquierda han visto los crímenes
incrementarse han visto abuso en sus
contribuyentes han visto autoridad
médicas y han visto a los principios
estadounidenses siendo descartados la
agenda
progres ha hecho que muchos
estadounidenses abandonen estas
jurisdicciones y vayan a pastos más
verdes
[Aplausos]
para aquellas personas Florida para
tantos de ellos ha servido como la
tierra prometida nosotros
Nosotros hemos aceptado la libertad
hemos mantenido la ley y el orden hemos
protegido los derechos de los padres
hemos respetado a nuestros
contribuyentes y rechazamos la ideología
progresista
compartimos a los progresistas en la
legislatura los combatimos en las
escuelas los combatimos en las
corporaciones nunca nos rendiremos a
esta multitud progresista
en Florida todo esto se acaba
[Aplausos]
la gente viene acá porque nuestras
políticas funcionan en liderazgo
funciona nos negamos a utilizar a las
urnas a poner nuestros dedos hacia el
viento los líderes nos siguen ellos
lideran
[Aplausos]
nosotros establecimos una visión
nosotros ejecutamos Esa visión y
nosotros producimos resultados
históricos y la gente de este estado ha
respondido de una manera absolutamente
increíble
[Aplausos]
ahora mientras nuestro país se disminuye
el liderazgo fallido de Washington la
Florida está en el camino correcto
Yo creo que la supervivencia del
experimento estadounidense requiere una
revivir de los verdaderos principios
estadounidenses Florida ha comprobado
que esto puede hacerse nosotros
ofrecemos
ofrecemos un rayo de Esperanza
que muestran que hay Buenos días que
vienen de aquí en adelante me
enorgullece los logros que hemos logrado
En este estado Me honra su respaldo y
tengo la esperanza de ver el camino que
viene he luchado una buena batalla he
terminado la carrera en esta primera
curva y he mantenido la fe
hemos logrado más de lo que cualquiera
considerado posible Hace cuatro años
pero tenemos tantísimo más por hacer y
solamente he empezado a luchar Dios los
bendiga a todos Muchas gracias a todos
Muchas gracias por una victoria
histórica y avasalladora